hello
i'm paul calling with film independent
and welcome to this week's coffee talk
uh coming to you from a very uh ac
chili palm springs so i've got a little
scratchy throat but
i've been staying inside so i think it's
nothing more than just
suffering from the ac for those of you
who don't know us film independent is
the non-profit
l.a based arts organization that
produces the film independent spirit
awards
plus yearly uh screenings
conversations workshops and filmmaker
labs a membership zone to everyone and
you can find out more at
filmingdependent.org
uh this week uh we're mixing up things
up a bit and we're going to have
three amazing creative producers join us
uh
they are responsible for some of the
most acclaimed films
of the 90s and 2000s uh first up is the
la based producing team behind bonafide
productions they are known for their
superb
taste and they have a knack for finding
original stories that connect with
audiences
their first produce feature was stephen
soderbergh's third film king of the
hills one of my favorites
and they went on to produce crum cold
mountain
the season little children low down and
juliet naked
they are two-time spirit award winners
for election
and little miss sunshine and they were
oscar nominated producers
and spirit award nominated for nebraska
the most recent release
was last year's peanut butter falcon
which is one of the biggest
indie hits of last year please welcome
albert berger and ron yoxer
here they come hey albert your mic is
muted right now
hey hello hello everyone is uh
semi-masked up how you both doing
we're doing okay hanging in there like
everyone else
doing our best every shishi mosque you
have that wrong
pardon me very chic mosque you have oh
yeah this is um
yeah the guy in the neighborhood makes
these
it was a real issue whether to wear one
that the cleaners made or where one that
this other guy made
i'll i'll change it uh mid mid
seminar shopping locally that's here and
you are both
um i've seen in santa monica obviously
in different countries right um
are you in you're both from the west
side uh no i'm in the hollywood hills
canyon and uh ron is actually in culver
city there
at our uh world headquarters right you
live in santa monica they're wrong right
yes i do
yep and uh joining us from the
east coast um is the new york-based
producer who started her career in the
90s
uh at ted hope and james sheamus is
coming good machine
uh she then founded this is that with
ted hope anthony bregman
and diana victor uh both companies were
responsible for some of the most
acclaimed films of the past 30 years
including uh
itunes tanyan crouching tiger hidden
dragon
and the eternal sunshine of the spotless
mind as a producer her credits include
the savages
adventureland the american uh 20th
century women and can you ever forgive
me
and she won the spirit award for the
diary of a teenage girl
she's currently president of production
at archer gray
in new york uh so pleased to welcome and
kerry
to join us where are you anne here she
is hi
hi guys hello hi
how are you doing i'm good thank you
hanging in
in new york city pretty good yeah
this has disturbing echoes of the dating
game
the three of you here um the way this
works is i'm going to step
off this virtual stage for about half an
hour and let the three of you kind of
talk
shop for 30 minutes and we'll take
questions
um after 30 minutes those listening in
can
use the q a button at the bottom of the
screen here and i'll come back to take
some of those questions
try and get through as many as possible
but for now i'll let the three of you
take it away
thanks paul
i'm so ann what's your outlook on
the world of entertainment today
um what is my outlook on the world of
entertainment
i'm i want to go back to movie theaters
that's what i really want to do
i really wish i could go see the
david copperfield movie in a theater in
new york city this weekend
more than anything but i can't so i hope
to be able to do that soon
i wonder i wonder when things are gonna
uh return to any kind of
normalcy i mean how is your uh working
ben
um you know we've been developing like
crazy but
uh in no hurry to race into production
on anything
yeah we've also been developing a lot of
stuff we had movies that i'd hoped
to make this fall that pushed um
one of them uh features
uh the protagonist is an elderly woman
and because there's no insurance no way
to keep
her guarantee safety that's one that
we've had to push until i don't know
when actually i guess until there's
some sort of medicine or a vaccine and
the other one
um again we just couldn't get it off the
ground in time so we pushed to the
spring the only thing we have been doing
lately which has been kind of fun is uh
trying to do that is a little bit of
production is trying to do some
documentary
work which we've actually been doing by
sending iphones to people and letting
them film themselves and then send them
back
to us so that's been at least making
something that's been fun
yeah we've got something like that going
to a documentary by the way i think
maybe we should mute when we're not
talking just because there's an echo i
think
but uh but uh anyway yeah there's that
and uh
also for the kind of films that at least
we have on the agenda that we're
supposed to make in may and then
kick to the fall then kick to the spring
the whole idea of uh
starting and then stopping just seems
unthinkable
um you know at least on the modest
budgets that
we'll be working on so it feels like at
least for the time being with our
narrative stuff
where we're gonna wait until the coast
is clear
and i also think insurance right we
can't get insurance for anything
that's the other tough that's the other
tough part of it on the independent
movies um i think amazon and netflix and
those companies that have the
you know the pockets to back it up or
still are under some insurance policies
have been able to at least resume
finishing things
yeah well it's a good time for reading
that's for sure
yeah um i did see five guys like in a
black
unmarked van the other day around the
corner from my house
with a camera so it was clear that
somebody's trying to shoot
something in new york city yeah
yeah well that's good um i guess new
york is uh
is doing well huh at the moment i think
we're doing
uh better obviously we had a really
really really rough
start but right now our numbers are
pretty low i think our infection rate is
under one percent and i think we've
the whole state's only got
hospitalizations of
probably under 600 people and no our
numbers are our numbers are really good
right now the question is how to
how to keep them how to keep them that
way but uh so far so good and they've
started a little bit of production
um for outside shooting and soap operas
and stuff like that but no
no real features mounted yet i think
people are trying and i think tv is
going to try to come back
so um do you see any um
either benefits or long-term changes on
the
landscape of being an independent film
producer brought on by
the way people have been consuming films
in the last six months or so
you know i think it'll be really
interesting i don't know what you guys
have thought
i certainly feel i had projects that
even six months ago
felt makable that now maybe feel less
makeable
just because of the logistics of the
project or
maybe the the tenor of the subject
matter and likewise i've had things that
i felt
were going to be very hard to get off
the ground that might be
easier now because the subject matter
maybe feels a little bit more uplifting
or the story feels a little bit more
relevant or it seems
covid friendly in terms of production so
i think there's a lot of
that introspection going on uh back and
forth i really wish i had a movie that
was about three people in a house in
sardinia i could probably make that
yeah yeah although i think we're going
to be getting pretty sick of those
movies in about a year from now
have you found that uh you know you're
modifying any of your projects to
deal with the current circumstances um
we have one thing that we're
set to go and you know a lot of big
crowd scenes even though it's a small
movie
and uh you know we you know we really
want to
we really want to hold on to that but uh
we're just not quite sure
when when's the right time yeah i think
two of the things that i have have a lot
of crowd scenes but they're also
period pieces so i think the question is
can we build some of that
archivally you know if you i guess we've
looked at a movie like milk for example
and figured out how they
integrated you know news footage and
real life footage into the story we did
that on the movie
lost girls that i made we really because
liz garbus came from the documentary
world we used
a lot of archival footage to sort of
extend the reach of our movie
um just because we didn't have the
resources to
fill some of the stuff or we were
shooting scenes that we wouldn't have
been able to recreate
and i think that's led me to think about
how we can do that
how we can do that more and more um
which is kind of fun
and i'm looking for things that take
place in new york when the city is
really down and out because i think
that'll be easy to
that'll be easier to redo 1979 like
it's it's it's now yeah yeah
how about you guys yeah yeah that's when
uh that's when i was in film school
there i remember at fondly
199. i yeah
no we're um working away on stuff
uh uh we've got a couple things that
have been set to go for a while
um and uh you know uh
i anxious to get back to production but
um
you know as i say mostly it's it's uh
it's
developing you know that's we're in full
swing on that a lot of the zoom calls
which uh i'm
sure we're all suffering through or uh
doing uh
um i'm wondering do you have uh uh
like what is the next thing you're gonna
be doing i don't know
i honestly don't have any i honestly
don't have any idea um
i don't think it's the first time i've
said i don't know i don't honestly have
any idea i think i say that all the time
um but i really don't know
right now um which is a little
terrifying something will something will
come up
yeah oh it always does it always has you
know i think it's just a matter like i
said we're doing this documentary right
now and that's
kind of fun and then a lot of
development and
i don't honestly know what will go first
i have projects that need
that have studios and directors need
actors i have projects that have
great scripts and need actors so we can
get financing i mean i
i'm sure like you guys i have things in
every every single stage i have stuff
and development
for international tv co-productions and
maybe that'll
come together faster but i if i had to
if you said all you got to tell me what
your next movie is or i'll shoot you
you'd have to shoot me can you talk
about what your docs about or is that
under wraps it's a little bit under
wraps um
but it's sort of about
i think in broad strokes it's uh we're
doing
a small we're doing visits to various
communities around the country
um through individuals to ask them to
tell us how they're getting through
covid sort of emotionally and and
financially it's really about the
financial
impact on the most financially
vulnerable
americans so this started after cobit
uh the idea for this or the idea came
after coving we got a call from somebody
who was interested in
in uh exploring that idea and um
yeah we had it we have an interesting
thing where we had started a movie
before covid
um it's this thing about uh shia labeouf
started an acting school
in um south l.a uh sauce and wreck and
it's a
you know sort of the documenting of the
formation of that
school and the people involved and the
performance that they're
ultimately going to give and we were
able to just
as the world changed that theater group
had to change so
we were fortunate to be able to you know
just continue
working on it as they had to deal with
the new realities so
uh who knows where the whole thing's
going but and you know the whole
notion of live theater is you know is
anyone's guess
but uh given that we're still in the
middle of it um we're able to still keep
going so
i mean there is some really cool live
theater stuff and performance stuff
starting to happen in new york um
not necessarily film related but i just
love seeing how people are adapting you
know there are a lot of
what people are calling porch concerts
here right where little bands or combos
are showing up on
on porches or on street corners and
people can
can gather and those have been kind of
great and then there
was there's a theater thing happening at
um
one of the cemeteries greenwood cemetery
i think where they're saying
that you sort of get a you get an
itinerary and you have to follow
to different destinations within the uh
cemetery and it's sort of performative
and
interactive and i i'm kind of excited to
see how people are trying to
create stuff still during this i don't
know what version of that's happening in
la there has to be some version of that
happening there
well it's a you know there's been a lot
of interesting stuff with music in these
sort of um
on these screens you know these zoom
performance kind of things
and of course there's the drive-in idea
um you know with uh theatrical which i
haven't experienced
yet but um we are um
we had a film at sundance that uh you
know we were really really happy with
the way it went it was called the last
shift and it was very difficult though
uh the whole uh uh distribution climate
and
you know uh nobody acquired it for a
while but now all of a sudden there's
interest and
we'll be back on the festival circuit it
seems and um
as well as a distributor but this whole
notion of drive-in
is now uh you know now a big thing for
some of these film festivals and so
you know we'll see how that works yeah i
think the new york film festival is
doing outdoor screenings with rooftop
films and rooftop films here in new york
has been doing some
drive-ins and it's been it's been pretty
cool
hi um i've been getting technical
feedback from my wife
on text that i was possibly responsible
for the echoes so i've
been on mute and um now i just got a
text that i've been muted for too long
so i have to say it's not my wife just
came in and demanded
that you start talking so it's that's
good they're working on the concert
well i'm on a i'm on a uh ipad propped
up by a
box of uh antiseptic towels so
i have to reach up it's not a simple
stroke
anyhow though just along the lines that
there is a line here about
what what good is coming out of all this
you know it does seem like um like this
festival we like a lot
um middleburg and virginia's perhaps
doing outdoor screenings
and screenings from balconies um
at this hotel that looks out on the big
lawn and then
there can be drive-in screenings it just
seems like all over the place
people are finding new ways of gathering
and um you know in in small groups and
you know in a way i mean it's a terrible
thing overall but
it forces people to really kind of
rethink the
viewing experience and probably upgrade
wherever they live
and and uh get much more conversant with
all the platforms and what they really
need to
subscribe to to you know see the films
they want
and so in that way it's probably very
vital but in another sense it's sort of
like this
coffee talk where we have no idea except
for
my wife uh sending these remarks that um
there's anyone out there and that was
sort of the um
the main thing we'd hear from directors
even before
the virus was you know we're concerned
that maybe my film would go directly to
a platform
and how will i ever know what the
audience dynamic is like and how will
you know you have that thrill of your
friends and your relatives to see the
film and now
it's sort of gone full circle where how
can we get our film on a platform
um but you know i think keeping things
live even
in these festivals when they show a film
that's kind of
pre-recorded or a discussion that's
pre-recorded you know
it has so much less interest if you
think you can see it anytime
or that's not actually happening at the
moment like
whoever is watching this if they see it
later you know
it was live because it's 12 19 on
thursday in l.a
but otherwise it's you know some of the
stuff you see
maybe for a while i think i'm seeing
something as it happens only to find out
it was recorded two days ago
so anyhow that's all to say however
they do it i think festivals should
have a live component even on the
internet so people
have the sense they're actually
experiencing something as it happens
no i think that's i think that's
definitely i think that's definitely
true but i do feel there are
ways to watch and see things and you
know i feel like every
week i'm making a list of things i want
to see and things that are coming out or
old movies that are showing up someplace
and i i feel i mean it's always hard to
keep up with things but i
i think it's i think it's harder now and
i'm trying to balance that if i stare at
my screen
all day on zooms do i want to stare at
another screen later so i think it's
about
finding that finding that right balance
but i do think there's a lot of exciting
stuff to
to see out there so that's been kind of
fun um
well maybe we should put uh the covid
thing behind and
move to the portion where we grill you
about your work
yeah um i had a question for you um
how how did uh a diary of a teenage girl
um come about because that's a movie i i
really
loved when i saw it i saw it recently it
really holds up how did that
all come together uh
mar it came in in a funny way mari and i
had been
talking about doing a whole another
project that was based on this american
life story this is my recollection of it
and
uh in the we were working to get the
rights figured out and at the end of the
day
the woman decided she didn't want to
have her life adapted uh so that sort of
fell
fell away and it was kind of one of
those but what what else have you got
kind of conversations you know because
we had enjoyed that process together and
she brought up
that she had optioned uh
the graphic novel diary of a teenage
girl and was
had written a theater version of it and
was just about to perform it
down in a theater down i go like that
down downtown in the theater downtown
and um
and i had known the i knew the graphic
novel uh
and liked it and uh was excited by that
idea
and um she
did a great job with the play and and i
think
felt afterwards that it wasn't out of
her system that she wanted to keep
trying to
to work work it you know wanted to stay
with that story and could it
really work as a as a film and um she
hadn't directed any
film stuff before she'd been an actress
and a writer and theater and um
and really the sundance labs were super
important because
um we got support from the labs for her
to go to the writers lab in the
director's lab
and i think there she was a rock star
there because she's a rock star
and uh we came away with a little bit of
financing to start to think about
casting and budgeting and how to put the
movie
uh together and um
and then worked to put the producing
team together
um we had uh
a great group of women involved in in
producing that movie but really
it was all about us just keeping up with
mari right it was one of those you know
it's
it's that beautiful experience with a
first-time writer director where
and i've had this a couple of times i
think todd field was this way you know
i didn't produce that movie directly but
but good machine did but um i had been
involved early on where you just feel
you're just keeping up with them right
it's not like you're going to make their
movie with them you're just going to
be there to help them make smart
decisions and mari was that way i mean
she just
took off and it came together and was
smart about the budget and
smart about the cast and uh it was a
tricky one to cast
casting the role that became the alex
skarsgard
role was hard because it was very
challenging to find
somebody who was brave enough to play
that role and not be
icky i mean there were a couple of
people who wanted it and you'd think
like oh my god that would be a very icky
version of a movie but i think he was so
uh sort of gentle and seemed sort of
naive and ill directed you know but you
didn't ever really seem malevolent and i
think that was a super critical part of
that and then sort of the discovery of
bel powley
was just a gift and kristen wiig
obviously was a huge
anchor piece to making the movie you
know watchable and seeable but it was
really
and then mari finding the animation
version in the end you know
what animated and what didn't ant made
was really also helpful i think in terms
of
how to tell the story um about this
young woman's
sort of sexual you know coming of age
um that's really how it came about
yeah i take it that kristen wiig was an
important piece as far as the financing
or at least
as you say anchoring yeah she she was
she definitely
was of those three actors um
the one who at the time added the most
value for sure i mean alexander
also because of uh uh what's the alan
ball show true blood you know he had
some international
appeal as well but it was not an
expensive movie and we had financiers
who were
um uh who were brave and
and smart and uh and we kept the number
you know we kept the number down
yeah well it was an incredible movie and
i i think um
you know really uh a great um instinct
of yours given that she hadn't made a
movie before but um
you know she's one of those rare people
she's made three movies and from my
point of view they're all great
and uh i agree you don't see that right
out of the gates um
so often i but it was just it sounds
like you just had a feeling
uh that um she could make that
transition from theater
or whatever yeah i mean she you know
like she just really like i said you
just
you could just feel it right it was just
like electric in her she was gonna
figure out how to get it
done so i you know i i just i was in the
right place at the right
time i think and was able to get some
support
and attention uh like i said through you
know sundance michelle
was so great and and ly and the whole
rachel chanoff they were really uh
they really they really saw it too so
that really that really got us the
momentum that we needed and phil
uh engelhorn from center reach was a big
part of it we got some good grants i
mean it was
challenging material there are
definitely people who
were not up for the risk of that story
um but it was kind of you know it was
kind of a
you either got it or you didn't kind of
kind of movie to me was super
super exciting to tell that those are
kind of great uh
things when you have a director that you
just have an instinct or a
great faith in and uh you know the whole
thing is uh
contributing but you know that it's
going to head in a very strong direction
i mean
those are always the easiest experiences
right um i mean you guys must be able to
cite those experiences when you felt
like this
you know i mean listen no movie is easy
to to make some are
some are more fun to make than others um
but i think when the director is that
clear
about what they want and also that
pragmatic about what they want um
you know solution oriented and really
really
pushing for what they want
but understanding the difference that
every decision is not a major decision
you know that i mean i think
that just is the best kind of uh
collaborative experience
yeah i mean that's always been our
experience with alexander payne for
instance where
you know it's it's um i you know that he
is going to make a great movie um you
you there's a huge leap that takes place
from the script to the the movie itself
the scripts are always very strong but
he really has in mind what he's going to
do and it's
um kind of remarkable to watch him on
set and work with actors and
often you know as a producer you'll have
an idea but
it's almost like you you can wait rather
than say it because eventually
you know he'll be trying it out if it's
a good idea
you know as well and it's just you you
know
and and also there's um often with those
kind of directors and
maybe mari's the same way you uh they're
they're the most collaborative
because um you know they know that they
can say no if you have an idea or
somebody on the
set has an idea um i you know they have
that
that confidence in what they can do that
they know
yeah exactly they're confident enough to
be open to an idea and confident enough
to
to hold their course but also um
i think that's super super important but
alexander doesn't write all his movies
right
just no but he always um uh
writes on them i mean initially him and
jim were
you know doing all the writing on their
movies and then eventually
you know nebraska was a script that bob
nelson wrote and uh
you know we've worked with him on other
things where he jumps in uh
though at a certain point and you know
uh does what he needs to do to bridge
the gap between where the script is and
where he wants what's in his what's in
his head yeah
um what are you guys going to do next
what's next for you
in a you know in a dream world yeah
we have a couple of things i mean
farnsworth house is something we've been
involved with for a long time do you
know that project at all i do
i do yes i like that project yeah
yeah yeah we've come very close richard
press
correct is going to redirect it and we
were supposed to start in may
so that's on the docket and uh we have a
small film
called miles that won the nickel award a
couple years ago
that we're just starting to cast and we
have a director
uh harula rose that is
filmmakers so we're excited about that
we're uh
working with ray romano uh on something
and you know so we've got a lot of
things that
um that are supposed to go but
you know uh we'll see you know we're
we're we're waiting patiently
impatiently uh the ray romano movie is
the
one said in queens right that one
exactly
that's a good one that's good so you'll
be over here i was thinking this morning
about
the summer that uh me and ted and
anthony were producing jessie perez's
movie on one block in staten island and
you guys were doing the todd fields
movie
around the corner on another block in
staten island and our crews kept showing
up to the wrong
sets i remember that well i remember we
came to visit you
there yeah little do we know we'd be
working with jesse years later on juliet
naked
that's right i love julia naked that's a
lovely movie
yeah he was a great uh collaborator
with him um but that was a that was a
funny hot summer i remember that
and there were this the locust the
cicadas were out so they were like
cicada carcasses
all over staten island which i remember
vividly
yeah i mean ron can jump in here but
we've had a a long
relationship with you ann and in some
ways it's been interesting because
we we kind of do the same thing this
sort of uh
bridge between you know the studios or
the searchlight type places and
independent films and although you're in
new york and we're in la
and often you know adapting from books
and uh there was even that one weird
moment where we were
looking for a fund together with uh our
dear pals steve goin and ted
anthony bregman and who else was
involved with that ron
was there another uh party
there was a third party wasn't it was it
michael london am i making that up was
it i don't think
no i think it was you guys steve golan
and
and and us ted anti i don't know that
there was another one
christine wasn't involved was she i
don't think so i don't think so yeah
that's all that i remember yeah yeah
that was a different time which maybe
leads into um and albert whatever you
think about it just
every once in a while particularly we
have interns you know that are graduate
students
at you know ucla or if i or sc
somewhere and you know i think about it
in the sense that they're
like graduating coming into this
business but also
for people who are out there i mean
i guess the pollyanna side i say it's
kind of
the last 10 years maybe there's been a
very
interesting time to be a producer even
though there's
obvious difficulties but in a way
by being i guess what i'm alluding to is
it's more democratic as far as
access to information and tools and
and also the um proliferation of the
platforms
kind of make the buyers very clear and
obvious
you know at least on one level who to go
to
but how do you um what's your response
is this uh both the best and the worst
of times or or
more one than the other for a producer
i i would say i would say i think it's
about
the same um i still don't know what
movie i'm gonna make next
um i still am always reading and looking
for new
stories i still am trying to understand
what's working and not working
um i'm still trying to do the smoke and
mirrors of
how i can get a movie off the ground and
feeling inevitable
um with no money in place
um and there's lots of different ways to
get
movies out there i i think it's just the
i always think about it as being sort of
the appetite
the appetite for the volatility you know
i always think like
i think you know independent producers
and
writers and directors have potentially a
greater appetite
or interest or abilities to sustain the
the volatility and i think
you know agents and managers television
executives
probably less so um but if i
you know i was again going back through
some
sort of notes and various years i always
used to collect the uh
the you know the keynote speaker the
from
you know from the gotham awards or from
the spirit awards and
you know i remember joe drake gave one a
bunch of years ago that i i still give
out to students and
young interns and producers just about
how to find your story and fall in love
with it and stick in it and
you can look at all the things that
don't happen or you can look at all the
things that did happen so i do think
it's a glass half full glass half empty
thing
um obviously people need to earn a
living and that's hard to do on super
low budget movies but
it is a luxury to do this right i mean
what we do and
i think if you've got the stomach for
the volatility of it i don't know
i don't actually know that it's harder
now maybe there's more different kinds
of people calling themselves
producers now right there's a new
producer management company that started
and there's
uh so what is a producer i know is
something that producers talk about
all the time who really produces um
whatever that means
and i think i like producing with
partners i think there's all sorts of
different ways to be producers but i
i don't like to be called a producer
from the 1990s because i feel that i'm a
producer today so
i and i still have to figure it out the
same way i don't know what do you think
yeah we were really working more than uh
you know we were making more stuff than
ever uh before
the virus but it is very frustrating
these days because of um
distribution it's just sad to see that
you know
that's such a difficult um bridge to you
know
to get over i mean both with peanut
butter falcon
and with this movie the last shift that
was just at sundance um
we thought you know uh both films were
great and
god it took like a year to find a
distributor on peanut butter falcon
nobody
wanted it forever and hard to get it
into festivals and
you know we knew in that case that was
an audience film and uh
with this one um you know it's a movie
about race and class in the midwest
right now
and uh you know on some level what could
be
more timely but i you know you just do
not
easily have that option anymore and we
we probably made 30 films and never had
a film
you know that didn't get distribution so
you know it's really turned into a
battle
and uh uh you know i it's not like we've
got anything against streaming but it is
hard to duplicate that experience of
seeing
something in a movie theater with an
audience and uh particularly when
it's a audience-friendly movie i mean
you can't
get that at home uh sleeping on the
couch so
i don't know i mean i don't mind the
streaming thing and i you know i made a
movie last year with liz garvez this
movie lost girls that was at amazon
and we didn't figure it out at amazon
and we moved it to netflix it was um
and uh that movie had a life at netflix
that it never would have
had had we made it theatrically you know
we were able
to make it with exactly the cast that we
wanted and weren't driven by sort of
foreign sales models of movie star
chasing and it had a very large
outreach uh again larger than i think it
ever would have had theatrically and
they were very supportive of it so no
sure i i just meant
more more comedies or more that
you wanna you know you feed off of the
response to the movie
um streamers is they keep saying they
don't want
you know i had this conversation with
somebody there they don't want art house
movies or what they would call art house
adjacent movies where we've probably
made
the vast majority of our movies those
don't uh those don't really
rise to the top at the at the streamers
unless they have super
fancy movie stars in them but you guys
should feel great about peanut butter
falcon it's a movie that i came to
very late but it played across the
street from me at the angelica
movie theater forever and i i
bought a ticket went and sat in the
movie theater and saw it and had a
phenomenally
enjoyable time but you guys proved
everybody wrong i mean you that's a
hugely successful movie you should be so
happy
yeah we are happy but uh in the year it
took to
you know find a home for it it wasn't
there wasn't a lot of joy at that point
but um
but yeah i mean roadside did a great job
with it and those guys are great
yeah and our our partners from the
armory who we produce the movie with uh
actually uh you know finance the release
so
uh you don't always have that luxury but
yeah but uh anyway
so uh ron what do you think
um well yeah i'm sorry for this second
delay do you guys hear an echo or is it
okay i don't know
i have no echo you sound perfect no okay
great
well um no i just
that's all true i mean it is a um
i mean i think this year will be in
every way
you know a huge uh whatever you want to
call it pivotal or transformational
year for the culture and for
entertainment
and you know the market forces obviously
have changed what audiences
expect in certain you know places like
and say
when you say you can't wait to go back
into a theater
you know that's um it's going to be
very interesting what kind of films
really
pull people to come back i mean
obviously
the the default is you know huge
visual experiences that you know um
but you know will there even be the kind
of um
wrenching drama or something or or
smaller film that used to exist
but you know overall when you have
so many buyers on platforms and you know
it's somewhat of a
mystery exactly what they want or what
their algorithm
you know supports but it is
a time where there's a lot of buyers a
lot of competition
and a lot of serious films end up on
platforms films that you know
we like and would be happy to make so in
that way it's very optimistic
i'm sure there's a a whole array of
their best performing films
is like what netflix released a couple
weeks ago
that are not films that we probably
would make
but um just as long as there's a decent
sized audience
um you know it's it's it's good to have
that outlet
but i even meant in the broader sense to
some degree
it's been happening for years that this
kind of exclusive
country club aspect to who
is making films financing films you know
producers it's something that oddly
i think probably all three of us have
missed
i mean we don't regret missing it but we
haven't been part of it that it's just a
kind of structure that is
is is waning or disintegrating or
whatever along with a lot of other
things but in
in place of it is something very you
know
vibrant and and if it ends up that
the platforms do well and theaters come
back
um substantially you know we've kind of
improved
uh you know both both forks in the road
um but i think just overall i was asking
about
you know i just it just seems like so
much of the skills that a producer might
want to talk about or or need or that
used to be
a couple of elite film schools you know
there
a lot of that is available
on the internet and it you know was in
person it's always you know what i said
you know you can go so many places
pre-virus
to hear talks that are the same thing
that
you'd pay a lot of money if you went to
an elite film school
but you're getting the same information
and and you know on
it just seems now on the internet with
like the sundance lab
and my dear producer and all these
places where you can get a lot of
very very helpful information on
everything
that is kind of the same subject as
would be covered um in um graduate
school
so anyhow that's a plus side that you
know it's
it's it's kind of democratically all
there for everybody
i hope i hope that's true it would be if
it would be great if it was
it's true here's paul
hi paul hey you ready for some questions
i don't i hate to interrupt but
no bring it on so
um we have a lot of questions coming in
and more will will trickle in
uh as as we're chatting but so here's
one that you might think is a bit of a
loaded question from stephanie to all of
you
um are you open to reading new projects
and if so
how do we submit to you
no one wants to go
maybe i'll ask it this way um how do new
projects come
to you and part two of that question
how do writers get new writers get their
work
read well you know just to answer
the part that we're all hesitant to jump
in there
for fear that we'd be possibly
first guilty about you know it's it's
it's tough because when you take in a
project
um you know you're under the
responsibility of reading it
and then that's a
burden right there um but it has the
potential
i guess joy of discovering something
that's good
that you know um i think a great story
is
the kind of screenplays that we've found
in a very unknown
unorthodox way you know they didn't come
from agents they weren't
you know something that was traditional
hollywood so
those are great satisfying stories for
us so in that way
we're very open i only say that because
there's probably
i don't know how many people are on this
coffee talk but
probably a couple saying um well how
come you haven't gotten back to me on my
script if you're so damn open
um but um overlooking that
we are kind of open to talk about
scripts
um it's much better if someone emails us
with the idea or premise because 95
percent
of scripts that might be actually
excellent scripts but they're not
in our wheelhouse or sweet spot or
however you want to describe it it's
just not something we do
um so to get the whole script on
something we'd never do no matter how
good it is
um you know that's sort of a
undesirable so i would say how we handle
it it's great if they have a lawyer or
whatever but
if they just send an email with i have a
script and here's the premise
does that seem like something you'd want
to read
i would say also with all of us all
three of us um you can tell
what we do do by the work we've done and
so you know
simply by looking at our films you know
you'll be able to tell whether it's even
in our ballpark
and uh that might uh you know spare
somebody writing the letter but i think
i think ron's right it's good to know
what it's about
uh first yeah i think so i mean i i also
think
in addition to that um i have been
involved in producing a
handful of movies that are periods
coming of age movies right and i think
i've been involved in making some really
good ones so i think the reality is i
might not want to make another one of
those i might want to tell a story that
i haven't told already so
like you guys i'm i'm my company is
small
myself an exec creative executive
assistant an intern or two
we read everything ourselves if it comes
in our obligation is
always to our own projects and things
that are going to generate the income
that we run the company on
um so to some degree you know we're not
going to take on
untested unproduced
screen writers very often and our policy
would be to
to not take those scripts in and when i
get that letter that says to whom it may
concern i've written 30 unproduced
screenplays would you like to read one
my answer is no
but when i get the letter that says you
know dear aunt kerry
i like the work that you've done and i
respect what archer grey does and i've
seen your most recent work and i have
something that that i'd love you to take
a look at and this is what it's about
and this is who i am
i might we might answer that one because
it's felt like you said like it's been
directed
to us and it's very specific and the
sender has sort of done their
research yeah i was about to say that
people should do their homework right
don't you
just sort of passed every producer in
town i mean i 10 well
i would say 10 well focused
emails is going to be a lot more
effective than 100
unfocused emails um
this next question is kind of related to
this um
it's an anonymous question but they're
asking if you have advice for early
career filmmakers
directors specifically to leverage their
micro budget
feature films to get future jobs as
directors
you know one thing that comes to mind
was uh the guys that made peanut butter
falcon
i you know we got that script from a
very close friend who said you got to
read this and
along with the script they did an
unbelievable
uh what's it called again like a proof
of concept
where they took every scene in the movie
and filmed about 10 seconds and uh
zach you know the lead actor was in it
so you could see that zach could carry a
movie
they made like a boat um they had a real
diy
sensibility and they knew where to put
the camera and
you know you just kind of breezed
through this thing and uh
i you know it was you could tell that
they
they both had you know great passion for
making the movie and they
knew what they were doing and you know
that the actor
could carry it so uh that was um you
know i'm not always
uh proof of concepts you know i can take
or leave but that one was
one that that combined with the script
you really felt there was something
there
a question from john um asks you
do you as producers kind of share
projects with each other
like if it's not quite in your
wheelhouse would you recommend it to
another producer
i i think we've shared projects with one
another i think we've looked for
projects to do together and
i think you guys uh so
i think our taste has been compatible
enough that and frankly we've probably
competed
for things over the years um
but i if there's something that i love
that's not
for us for one reason or another for my
company one reason other i
i would always like to see if i can help
but get a hand up but certainly
as compatible as our tastes are we've
definitely done that it's our highest
level pass
when we get a project and we say well we
can't do it but we should send it down
and one day we'll find one to do
together
a question here from jim says do you
think there's anything
from this pandemic that will carry over
post pandemic that will change the way
we work for the better
probably won't fly to la anymore for one
day meetings
that might go away um i think a lot of
work will be done this way i mean
right more pre-production will be maybe
done remotely
i don't no i think people will be
smarter about their
their time and their resources because
we're going to have to absorb the new
costs of the pandemic for a while
yeah which is not inconsiderable these
budgets um
that we're looking at are you know so
much more expensive uh
i mean i guess it's just gonna um force
people to really
tighten their belts and really figure
out ways to make
even more frugal movies um you know
given the
added expenses i read a great article
recently somewhere in all the great
articles that one reads these days about
um movies and romance and movies and sex
and movies and it was saying you know go
back to a movie like casablanca
or some of the pre-code movies to
understand how
films were made that really conveyed
you know romance and sensuality without
being overtly graphic or
frank or something and and i think there
will
and i thought that was an interesting
article because i thought you can
continue and i have a project right now
that has a
tremendous amount of pretty
uh has a lot of sex in it and we're
trying to figure out how to
do it and i think how to shoot it and
what's both appropriate for the actors
to do and what's appropriate for
covet and all that but i i thought that
was i read that article thinking there
are ways
very sexy movies have been made
throughout the years um
in what are probably now covidien uh
circumstances
yeah i mean is there gonna be a post
pandemic
movie in the same way they're a post
cell phone movies and pre-cell phone
movies where
they have a an effect on the plot and
what people do because
when you have a cell phone you don't
have to run to a pay phone and stuff and
a post-pandemic world where we look
differently on as you said sex scenes or
um crowd scenes like parties and stuff
i don't know are people going to watch
movies with people wearing masks
i don't know like nobody's really made a
good 9 11 movie maybe some things just
maybe you just we're just going to wait
for a new present tense maybe there's
like
maybe there's no i feel like there's no
present tense right now it's very hard
to figure out how to tell a story
right now really true
really true yeah we've discussed that
quite a bit you know like
films that could be said five years
previous
to now um there's
advantages to set them there then you're
not having people say well hold on
why are there 100 people in a bar
dancing yeah
but you know it might be like anne's
indicating
you know there might be up ahead a time
where you know i mean we're living in
like
historical changes really uh
on speed like never before so a year
from now
a lot of things are going to be a lot
different we hope
um you know in every category
um question from patrick hey patrick do
you
see audio stories like homecoming or
demi moore's
dirty diana as a good way for writers to
break into the business
and by p
but it seems to have worked really well
um on those
uh ones your site i mean it we haven't
had that experience ourselves but it
does seem like a great way to
have id i agree
i mean can you talk further about ip do
you think this is
something that is going to be a thing
for the next sort of
decade where um spec scripts just don't
find a footing anywhere in the business
i hope everybody's writing a spec script
right now there should be a lot of good
spec scripts after this i would
i would think so ron's probably writing
a spec script and you don't even know it
but
um i don't know i think ip seems like
such a television thing right some
isn't ip really the idea that oh it
worked in one market so it'll work in
another it was successful over here so
there's a pretty good chance it'll be
over here i think it's a risk-averse
idea i mean sometimes other other times
it's just i like working from books and
underlying material because it's there's
so much
subterranean stuff write your movie sort
of the iceberg and underneath all the
water is all that other stuff that you
got from the novel so i just think it
makes for richer
oh go ahead and i'm sorry no that's it
yeah i was going to say we've had an
interesting
thing recently where um i you know we
saw the movie running on empty again and
thought it would be
um you know make a really excellent uh
there'd be an excellent sequel to that
movie
and so in essence that movie became the
ip
for a 30 years later story uh that we're
working on with naomi foner who
wrote the original screenplay as well as
uh griffin dunn and amy robinson who
produced it and uh you know it almost we
were thinking it would almost be really
cool to envision a double feature where
you would
sort of re-experience the original film
and
uh and then see where these characters
are 30 years later
uh at least the ones that are still
around as well as new characters the
grand
kids and this and that so um that was an
interesting uh
thing that we're experimenting with and
we're also looking at
documentaries that are the basis for a
future film
you know an adaptation from uh
you know a uh whatever just a straight
documentary i wonder if my
if i'm feeding back again but um
yeah so we like to find it from magazine
article to
documentary obviously books that tom
verrada we've worked with several times
books are great um and i don't know
if we didn't jump in on saying we want
to do a project with you i was smiling
because we already have it took us
uh but we look forward to doing more in
the future we took a project
and tried to keep kicking it into
the present zeitgeist in the change of
uh
you know social dynamics um and you know
we made a noble effort i think but we
tried i just meant like get it all the
way there
yeah yeah yeah we had a good time
failing but we did
we did fail or we just decided it was
time to move on but um well you know a
lot of
a lot of films it's an interesting stuff
a lot of films that were considered
great films
you look at them now and you think wow
what a
you know out of touch tone deaf
you know sexist whatever and that was
the
great romantic comedy at the time and
you just said
the world has really changed you can't
tell that story
yep yeah a lot of 80s movies are like
that
yeah but he experienced many times where
you know it takes 10 years to get
something made and by the time you make
it
you think you know you and you even know
you know that gee
if only we could have made this five
years ago would have worked perfectly
but you know on some level you can't say
no once you finally
get over the hump and so it's a real
dilemma you know when
you you know when you're allowed finally
allowed to make a movie and
where it fits in the culture and all
that so i think i had the opposite
though i think i had the benefit on can
you ever forgive me because when i
started making that
no one really wanted to make a movie
that featured an
angry uh 50 year old woman and and by
the time i made it it was
the world was ready to listen so we i
almost
benefited you know i almost had the
opposite reaction
well i have to say that was one of the
greatest producerial feats given that
you
almost made it once with the director
and
actors and that didn't work and you put
it back together within a year
or something it's a remarkable thing and
that's a great movie
so thank you and a question here from
will asking you for some sort of career
advice he's a recent
mfa producing an enrollee and asks
what's the best thing
uh he can do whether it's networking
script reading job at a production
company
or make short films etc to uh
advance his career what can any
any aspiring producer do to advance
their career
well you know the great thing about
being a producer is that uh
you don't exactly need any
qualifications all you need is a piece
of material
and an idea of who you want to align it
with i mean ron and i learned that
at sundance in 1989 where we had a book
that we
had you know convinced a writer to let
us have a free option
and we stumbled into the first screening
of sex life's videotape
and met with steven soderbergh
afterwards in a little scrum of people
and
tried to get him to do it and it turned
into our indirectly into our first film
which he directed um but uh
uh yeah you just need to love something
enough
and figure out how to get it out into
the world
so but all of the things you mentioned
paul
are or you know or that the
questionnaire mentioned are good you
know getting a job
aligning yourself with a community of
people going to
film festivals uh when they come back um
and but you know falling in love with a
piece of material that's the most
important thing i think i agree i agree
with that and and there's
um there's no you know the there is like
you said there is
in inexpensive material out there and
there's a you know people can find it
but it's falling in love with something
or or aligning yourself with the
filmmaker i mean i think the places i've
seen
young filmmakers producers and
filmmakers
go off the rails i think is when they
wait for something to be the perfect
opportunity
right like i'm gonna i i think i need
three million dollars but i only have
one and a half it's like if you have one
and a half million dollars make your
movie for one and a half million dollars
right just like
run at the run at the wall if you're 75
there don't wait for the perfect
scenario um
i was always a person who needed to have
a a job so i worked at agencies and i
worked for producers and i did script
reading and you know i um
i wasn't or you know worked at
production companies and those
built networks i remember you know i
always felt like well i'll be at this
job for a year and i'll meet two people
and i'll go to another one and then i'll
meet two more people and i'll go another
one like and you sort of build a
a network that way and um
but at the same time i had that file of
movies that i was going to make
one day and some of them i've made and
some of them i hadn't so i think it's
that juggle
i mean this is kind of connected to that
first question but how does a
young producer find like
screenplays without being overwhelmed
you know not having a track record well
that's another thing it seems like
there's so many places to find those
screenplays i mean
you know there's all these lists online
you know
starting i guess first with the
blacklist but all these other
platforms of screenplay contests and and
showcasing screenplays from you know
graduate schools that are
online it seems like you know it's a lot
of work because you have to narrow down
what you're really interested in but i
probably no other time has so many
thousands of screenplays been out there
that are theoretically
you know there for the examining um
but just to bounce out what albert said
i think you know yeah you gotta
have some emotional connection and love
the project for
you know a personal reason or at least
it's
compatible with your worldview and so
you really you don't want to see it out
there
but i would say the other thing is to
which is not our strong suit but to
really understand
the market forces and the way businesses
are operating now
and what you know what kind of films
are actually doable because a lot of
films we love when you look back on them
and some we've made you just couldn't do
now no matter how much you love it
and even though it's a worthy film and
so you could spend a lot of time
um just holding on to this
script or book you know that
maybe has no viable way to production
yeah also i would add that um when we
first started for years and years um we
were nobody was sending us scripts be
or you know because we didn't have a
track record and where we really
made our mark was on books that fell
through the cracks and
uh you know certainly um
this boy's life turned into king of the
hill for us which was our first movie
cold mountain was something you know
picked up on the counter at folk soup
that had been
passed on by all the studios and hadn't
yet been reviewed so
from big to small tom perata's book
election was an unpublished manuscript
that
you know a friend of ron's uh turned us
on to
tom as a writer and we called him about
another book that
he was working on and he said i'm not
done with it yet but
i've got this unpublished manuscript
that uh election that is
somehow trapped between being a young
adult novel and a literary book
and would you like to read it and he
told us what it was and we thought yeah
that sounds great and so
you know those are where we had our
initial opportunities and then
eventually
you know things like ultimate sunshine
would show up and you know
and and it got a lot easier but uh but
yeah it took some time before uh people
will trust you with a screenplay
and also i'd say you know it's always
good not to go down the
well-beaten path uh like you know uh
if they exist again go to the uh you
know
smaller film festivals um really small
ones regionals
because people will go there because
their films there and
you know they're they're you know
looking to break out themselves
and if festivals don't come back to life
early early on
you know sign up for the virtual
festivals you know some of them are six
dollars a ticket or
forty dollars for the whole festival and
and you know everyone wants to be at
sundance in can
and new york but there's you know 150
other festivals and
same thing for literary material there's
like small journals
and and book review journals and
literary journals and
um you know sometimes
great articles are found in smaller
publications
or they turn you onto a book that just
was not
discovered for a variety of reasons
maybe it's a university press
or it was just overlooked also
books that didn't seem to speak to the
zeitgeist
10 or 15 years ago might be just right
for now but they've
you know been overlooked um is it still
possible to get
like you mentioned a free option you've
got on
absolutely 100 yes you can absolutely i
mean
i don't know that you can get a free
option on a new york times
bestseller right now but if you fall in
love with something it's a short story
it's uh
um a book that has been out of print for
a while and you can convey i think in
order to do that
when we've been successful doing it it's
because we've been able to make a
compelling argument about who we are and
what our point of view is and that we're
going to make it a priority and be
active on it and that you know
so many authors have been burned by the
film business and having things
optioned and made and not made or
they're skeptical about it when
we when i approach anybody to ask for a
free option or very inexpensive
option it is about always being able to
say i've got a point of view and a
passion and i'll take good
care of it because that's what you're
that's what you're selling it at that
point
i also would say as young producers
there's a real economy
in concentrating on writer directors
because you only have to hire one person
right the writer and the director in the
same body you don't have to get a writer
and then get to a script and get another
director
working with writer directors
is a you know is a is a very good thing
to do when you're starting out as a
as a producer because it's all in you
know your you
it's all it's all there i mean it's a
dangerous game but you can also with an
older piece of material you find out
it's available
if you can figure out how to get it to a
writer director then
you skip the odd the free option and
double back to a buyer with a writer
director
and you know you could always lose the
project but uh
um but that's another thing that you uh
you know if you don't feel you have the
track record to convince somebody to
give you a free option
just try and get it in the hands of
somebody that can make it happen or
partner with another producer you know
with a morris
bush producer the other thing i guess i
was going to say
ron's point which i think is a really
good one about the marketplace and maybe
they're
you know i think the the movies that
just are the sort of
independent execution dependent
dramas that were that used to be part of
i think
independent film scene that are so so
hard to make right now
but i think there have been some great
films made
sort of being smart enough to use a
genre to make a political movie right
you think of some of the movies that
have been made
in the last few years of get out
obviously comes to mind where you think
like
that was a movie that was a really about
something that just happened to be
also really fun to watch so i think the
producers i'm not figured out how to do
it it would be fun to do it to figure
out how to use a genre whether it's a
comedy and you guys have done such good
comedies or
or a slightly scary movie to create
something that has a plot and a motor
but it can still be about something to
me that's been a really
i i love to watch those movies i'm
always impressed with that
you know that's really that's really the
trick we're looking for as well you know
it's
it's sometimes people say i've got
something just up your alley
it's really dark and dreary and uh and
you know
social criticism that's unbearable no
that's not our ally you know the trick
is
that uh what you're saying anne that
there's
underlying ideas that perhaps are
the social critique but they're
underlying
a comedy and a interesting narrative and
a lot of energy and maybe some joy
you know embedded in it as well and then
you know a little sunshine is a great
example of that you know it's it's
full of social ideas not one character
says a thing about them
um we're pretty much out of time i want
to try and squeeze one more question in
uh before my final question um chad rick
actually there's two questions here but
chadwick asks
the three of you you worked with
incredible writers and filmmakers to see
an opportunity to leverage all that
creative power for tv
and ron we're dying to see your second
mask he says
and then alva says we'd like to see your
first mask i think she missed that
at the beginning these are all coming
from chadwick
oh there's someone else asked about the
mosque but chadwick
about tv and the second mosque
okay and tv the question was why don't
we
do some good tv are you planning to do
more in in the realm of tv because you
work with so many
great creative writers and directors
yeah we we
want to hop over that fence and do more
tv we have a couple things in the works
people told us five ten years ago that
tv is the future
i don't know why we didn't listen um but
we're
we're eager to be there now so yeah
it's um you know that's a big change in
our
whatever psyche or world view is you
know we love those moments i'm sure
anne's had great ones where you're in an
audience and
you wonder whether they're gonna you
know love your film or just walk out and
say
that was a bad experience because it can
go either way and we love those moments
but
you know i think the moment of having a
lot of people see your film
as television wherever it is on
platforms or
however it's delivered you know that's
an equally
somewhat more cerebral i guess but an
equally satisfying experience
and um i know albert's ready to with his
mass
i i have two more i can you know uh
display but albert what do you got there
well that that looks effective anyhow
yeah um the fight mosque yeah
yeah yeah no these are uh these i i
won't put them on but these are
you know it depends what mood you're in
what about writers i wouldn't like i
imagine someone like tom perotta
loves the idea that um
his novel the leftovers can can breathe
a lot more
right on tv and the writers
love the medium because their work is
not paired down but it's allowed to
breathe
yeah yeah yeah
writers are in charge and also you know
i think it's very much
uh the equivalent of a novel uh being
able to do
uh long form or to you know be able to
work in
on the canvas of a series um you know
it's i mean it's a different thing
because they're
you know by definition there's no ending
really to a series it's something that
can keep
spinning out but uh we're very much
trying to get our head around that and
we had a
a great experience uh on the leftovers
in the sense that we really
loved what uh damon lindelof and tom did
with it
and uh you know we were certainly
looking forward to
to duplicating that so
yeah and i think it's been fun the thing
i we're i'm definitely trying
to do tv enough television projects out
there it's been
funny because i think i have a you know
a brain that thinks sort of beginning
middle and end so the idea of something
going
on forever confuses me a little bit but
um
but i've also had projects that have we
started off this tv and now we've moved
them to movies and i have one thing that
started off as a movie and now we've
moved it to television
you know the idea of a limited series
sounds fun quibby seemed like a really
good idea i mean i love the
plastic quality right now that there's
so many different kinds of formats i
think that's
i think that's fun to think about where
does something best
fit it is a it's a good thing to think
on
so we're out of time but my last
question before we go
um is for your pandemic picks everyone
loves to know what uh
you could recommend because we're all
glued to the tv so much more now
it can be old new hidden gem
forgotten classic whatever you want well
that's the only question that
we know ahead of time paul because you
sent that an hour before the thing
started so um
father why did i always fight to say
godfather to
first so i just i brought the
box set out to palm springs with me to
try and
burn through all three but i haven't
started oh
burn through the first two yes i don't
know
yeah i know that that is great you know
there's stuff that
on the platforms maybe i wouldn't have
watched all of normal people or
or mrs america that were great to see
but
for for our time too i was talking with
a friend
and um you know it just seemed like
facing the crowd is a great old film to
see
um for our time and um
you know uh yeah those are my choices
yeah i i you know for me uh uh
i mean i think if you have a family
paper moon is sort of
a perfect movie uh that's always a great
one to see um
i saw recently we saw no direction home
which is the scorsese bob dylan
documentary which is
mind-blowingly great um i
you know uh running on empty as i said
before we saw that early in the
pandemic and that was uh um that was a
real revelation that's a
excellent excellent movie uh so those
are some
for me i think for me i i think i told
albert this we watched rear window
really on
in the pandemic because it such a good
new york movie and it's a movie about
being locked in your
apartment and seeing something happen
and it was great and grace kelly's
spectacular and it looks beautiful and
that was super super fun
on the sort of more current side i
really was blown away by i may
destroy you um i i just thought that was
so
powerful and and contemporary and fresh
um
and then i watched the ken burns
documentary about new york because it
just reminded me how much new york has
been through and that it will it will
will get through this
as well so i think those would be my
three
great my pick would be to watch uh hands
can you ever forgive me uh which i love
and to go back a little
um earlier back to the 90s for ron and
albert's king of the hill which i
watched actually
a couple of weeks ago and that it still
holds up i love that film
oh if you if you went all the way
through to the ending you saw ron
yerkes's acting debut he did
yes as the sort of super right at the
the new apartment exactly what was your
name again mr
donald miller donald miller yeah yeah
that
performance has been overlooked uh
unfortunately but thank you paul
woefully overlooked yes thank you
so yeah we're out of time i want to
thank you all for
for sticking with us and sharing so much
great advice for producers listening in
uh this has been a coffee talk from film
independent we will be back soon but
it just needs me to thank producer anne
carey thank you anne
thank you paul and at team bonafide
productions albert berger
thanks albert yeah and thank you for
inviting me guys
and ron yexus thanks rob yeah and hey
paul if it didn't get a big enough shout
out
um you know film independent is a superb
source of
everything uh screenings information
seminars workshops
yeah so that should be the first stop
for people
uh that's an answer to the question what
do you do if you're a
producer trying to get projects going
it's also great for networking and that
is of course is on hold right now
because we have no in-person events but
it's a great way to meet yeah you know
your future peers and these coffee talks
are subterranean places
thank you everyone yeah bye guys thank
you